oh no oh boy uh what is this isn't me I
mean what is that I'm not a little dork
and angsty I'm Elastigirl I'm you know
flexible yeah so the first one is is
your getting irritated about the fact
that that that everybody's jumping on
each other and you just want a moment of
sanity okay all right so there in the
new house this is a really grandiose
house but it's not particularly
something the incredibles will wind up
being comfortable in so it's sort of
impressive at first and then you realize
it's a highly impractical house right
can you make the ha ha more like a fake
good laugh though ha ha
no theme song or I'll turn this bus
right around cool now if you were to
make it a little more obnoxious like
very funny ha ha yeah the next thing is
you guys are sneaking out for a meeting
as mr. incredible and Elastigirl but
you're not wearing your masks you're
trying to hide it from the kids that
you're going out at night so the kids
are a little suspicious and they say
where are you going and you're heading
out the door well the fresh air is
especially good tonight the fresh air is
especially good tonight the fresh air is
especially good tonight good maybe make
it a little bit like a commercial the
fresh air is especially good tonight
excellent done
the implication is is that you cause a
lot of damage mr. incredible causes a
lot of damage so wait a minute you're
saying what I'm messy good and then take
a little bit of umbrage at that mess
messy wait a minute you're saying what
I'm messy when you say no that way
they'd be defensive about it I don't
know that way yeah maybe yeah exactly
let's try that I don't know that way why
wouldn't they change math math is math
math is math no lifeguard on duty swim
at your own risk
they've just had a kind of a rough
discussion and you're kind of appearing
in out of the fog okay and then he says
then bob says well where'd you go today
I noticed you missed all the fun
don't be mad because I know when to
leave a party I'm just as illegal as you
guys besides I knew the cops would let
you go he transforms into a monster and
Bob's used to this at this point but
you've never seen it so you're reacting
to it for the first time oh he is
freaking again he is freaking it just
what there are in public again this is
our chance follow them follow Frozone so
if we want to change people's
perceptions about superheroes we need
you to share your perceptions with the
world
I love superheroes the powers the
costumes the mythic struggles well it's
like a superheroes playground I'm so
sorry I'm late
we are in the green room of a TV station
and you're kind of sitting there you're
there with your brother kind of giving
an Elastigirl ascends up
the superheroes are coming up to your
the devic penthouse and so it's a very
impressive place and you're late for
this meeting and you're kind of coming
through the door with all your stuff you
know swapping out with all due respect
if you had handled the Underminer things
would have been different that's it
really you don't you don't go P at
beyondblue wonderful wonderful wonderful
Wow
I felt like an outcast before but now
with you being you I feel like getting
me the first scene here is all the
superhero the wannabe supers have like a
little party and and they don't know
that Elastigirl is gonna step into the
room and for your character that's like
having a rock star that she's always
admired to step into the room so you're
kind of overcome and you can't help
yourself
there you go oh wow Wow Elastigirl
there you are I didn't you Wow alright
okay cool maybe just a little bigger at
the beginning and you're trying to be
cool and failing miserably oh wow Wow
Elastigirl think there you are I didn't
know you yep
Wow come on get yourself together Karen
Wow good great now one more time and
when you say come on get yourself
together Karen make it like a private
whisper to yourself like
good can you call it out a little more
afterwards like because she's moving
away so as she gets away you're kind of
getting a little louder yeah yeah oh
yeah okay see you later talked good talk
dialogue change on one of these
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
um I know we pointed towards this one
would it be possible to scale this the
columns up and have fewer of them right
right right yeah good anything that yeah
this this layout here is ya know it's
great that lots of grass and trees and
stuff yeah yeah great
cool what yeah I love that his head
rotates like that the animators are
gonna go insane for them
they're absolutely gonna go bonkers a
few things about the case I was thinking
it could also I was wondering if the
Cape should attach along here yeah
that's great that's really cool yeah
yeah really really great fantastic yeah
I would love it if he if he slowed down
if he looked at him a little later and
then and then kind of went like this